[Musique]
hier alors que c'est tous les ans et
c'est franchement c'est une histoire
extraordinaire à chaque fois depuis la
prod a cassé la tirelire se sent
particulièrement ça va être un truc de
dingue
[Musique]
c'est une période magique mon ami si
c'est mon cadeau ce soir voir si ces
perruques ont pu remonter vingt ans en
arrière
est-ce qu'ils vont dans ce sens sinon
c'est que c'est tous mes potes d'enfance
au fait pourquoi donc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne veux plus rien
valérie est ce que ça va non quoi
comment ça mais d'après toi connard je
saute dans une voiture qui va apporter
dans les airs d'après toi est-ce que ça
va alors valérie vous m'avez jamais
parlé comme ça vous allez devoir prendre
là cliquez sur le capot rentrer dans la
voiture tu veux pas je prends juste non
mettre la clé dans le contact et mettre
le contact de la voiture d'accord
valérie sens pas si c'est bien pour
l'instant je trouve l'image show valérie
je trouve ça se passe très bien
soral et les voiles et voiliers
à bonne technique
mais valérie aller vite il reste quatre
golfeurs
voilà
ouais
c'est quelqu'un qui s'appelle sur
lorient cki florian je connais qu'un
vrai jeu par rapport
vous l'aimez bien florian ouais c'est
qui c'est un collaborateur qui
travaillent avec moi de ma société
c'est votre assistant florian et là ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lorient est ce que vous avez peur dans
la vie
vim ouais même que mathieu les serpents
lézards et n'essaie pas de contre les
serpents et les araignées sais pas trop
votre truc
non non non non c'est pas drôle non
cyril vous allez devoir vous 2,20 à vous
de vous soigner vous d une tutoie
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'ils attendent et
vous allez devoir aller chercher un
avion qui se trouvent dans les serpents
vous avez une minute déjà pour
parlementer entre vous deux pour ces
noirs qui va y aller il n'y a aucune
parlement tation attention tu as pu me
va y aller non non plus fine mais tu te
situes tu pas celui qui donnent les
ordres et moi je jetais jeter sortie du
caniveau ya deux ans
[Applaudissements]
bon ça baby show là si jamais tu n'as
plus de quoi donc ta copine soit on
constate oui barbare voilà chômage et
tout ça tu sais qu'il est entendu
soyez viry florian oui mais non tu
reposes la société b 35 secondes vite et
font vous sortir en avion ou en avion
là je suis vraiment extrêmement fiers de
toi sache le non non
dans les gradins
sagan
[Applaudissements]
un bébé to view salut cyril c'est
nicolas sarkozy
des informations très précises monte
indiqué que c'était votre anniversaire
ces informations n'ont pas dit quel âge
je voulais vous dire que j'aime votre
énergie que j'aime notre enthousiasme
que parfois même je peux me reconnaître
bon anniversaire suivi
[Applaudissements]
encore là
[Musique]
jean-paul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
j olala du fruitier du mois sa requête
avait choqué
[Musique]